the Joe Rogan experience yeah yeah
Python so it's not just the Everglades
right it's I'd read recently like 30
percent of all the birds in North
America are gone within the last that's
how skiers
live that's how scare ya have you ever
seen the numbers how many house cats how
many birds house cats kill billions
billions in just in United States but
they're cute adorable [ __ ] the
billions though killers billions of
birds like you see like scientists were
baffled when they did the actual survey
they found there were the real numbers
they're like this can't be real this
can't be right billions give a cat right
yeah - Kelly you had a whole bit in your
staff count yeah yeah I like cats I love
cats yeah they're they're interesting
creatures I had three of them in Spain
that's funny they had their own little
world you know yeah
three of them did what they wanted to do
the only bummer is litter boxes yeah had
them outside
gotta have them outside the house in my
neighborhood you cannot yeah coyotes
yeah and okay
how old are salami owls and coyotes yeah
those owls are a [ __ ] they'll
snatch them up just as quick as anything
yeah we have big owls out here so if you
were gonna die from an animal attack
what animal would you like to die from
you'd like a big cat because they would
kill you before they'd eat you yeah you
know yeah a bear will just eat you yeah
black bear will eat you
grizzly bears sometimes eat well they'll
[ __ ] you up and anyway this is what I
was told when I was in Alaska that you
played dead with a grizzly but never
with a black Wow hmm because some
Grizzlies that if they think you're dead
they'll kick some dust on you and come
back a week later when you're wanted
there like French people they want they
want a test and you know that's not
totally true it depends on how hungry
they are and whether or not they're old
but you are more likely to be attacked
by a black bear for predation right a
friend of mine was attacked recently
really yeah he had a he had a shoot a
black bear you know yeah he was he tried
to chase it off and he stumbled upon
there was a smell he's a
he stumbled upon this smell and the
smell was a dead cow and this black bear
had been eating this dead cow and he
tried to chase the black bear off and
the black bear decided try to go after
him and had to wind up shooting it he
had a rifle or pistol I think is a
pistol but it was it wouldn't stop it
wouldn't leave him alone just trying to
say get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah got thrown waving his arms you know
wolfed at him then it turned around and
came out him from another direction and
then it literally ran up within like 20
feet of him okay
we're done here that happened to me with
a monkey once really yeah treat the
monkey I didn't know did you feed him a
rat I this was in Malaysia I was in a
Botanical Gardens in Penang Malaysia I
actually told this book the story at the
beginning of sex at dawn and I was with
my girlfriend at the time and like your
situation in Costa Rica she wanted to
give some peanuts to these monkeys these
guys at the entrance were selling little
bags of peanuts and so she there was
this baby monkey hanging by his tail
over the trail where we were and she
pulled out this bag of peanuts and like
you know opened it and that attracted
all this attention from other monkeys
and while she was handing a peanut to
the baby this other monkey jumped out
from the bushes lepton her took the bag
of peanuts and was gone like in a flash
it was so happened so fast
she's screaming I'm like what the [ __ ]
it was just like holy [ __ ] and we're
surrounded by these monkeys they're
everywhere mm-hmm and that's why we
realized like all the local people have
these big sticks and we thought they
were walking sticks or something they'd
like to keep the monkeys away I didn't
have a stick so I got like but I was too
triggered yeah I got like [ __ ] you
monkey you know you leave my girl alone
he said that like Joe Dirt not into it
and yeah I felt like you know all this
testosterone adrenaline and I was
looking
and Hulk smash yeah so we you know 20
minutes later or in this sort of field
and there's a tree in the middle of a
field and they're more baby monkeys and
by now she's totally forgotten about it
she's like oh they're cute so I have the
peanuts now and she wants to give more
peanuts so I pull out a bag to give to
her and this monkey comes out of the
woods sort of a big one and he's like
looking at me and I'm just like [ __ ] you
dude like I'm three times your size [ __ ]
you and he sort of like moves you know
sort of does this thing and he's looking
at me and there's a branch and I picked
up the branch and threw it at him right
kind of like what your buddy is trying
to do with this bear like hey get the
[ __ ] out of here you know and this
monkey just looked at the branch land in
front of him and looked up at me and it
was like you [ __ ] up and he lept
over it and came charging at me with it
like these fangs yeah just coming
straight at me I went nuts I turned into
a monkey I just started going I was like
jumping up and down and spray and spit
everywhere and he stopped and when I got
and he's and my girlfriend screaming and
we're like ten feet away and then he
just like backed up but like yeah [ __ ]
you well primal moment whoa very primal
and he didn't plan that now if I had had
a stick it would have been necessary so
the moral of story is Carroll is carry a
stick when you're on walk softly yeah
carry a big stick
[Applause]